welcome to the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
cart rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i am dave
ramsey your host
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today here on the air
we're taking your calls about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two
five well over a year ago we start work
on a project
rachel writing her latest book and a
year plus
later all of that work comes to fruition
and today
is launch day on know yourself
know your money ta-da it's here it's out
oh i was telling my husband winston last
night we were going to bed i was like
i feel like my child is being delivered
in homes like all across america
because the books some of them got
delivered early so people yesterday were
on social
holding them up and and posting it and i
was like oh it feels like
my child is out there in people's homes
right now and
yeah i which winston would not allow by
the way but yeah but you can do that
with a book
not a real child not my real child but
uh
it feels like a child so it is it is a
is a long pregnancy it's a labor of love
in so many ways because i actually ended
up writing it almost two years ago
because i did it before i had my third
baby
because i wanted to spend maternity
leave not writing the manuscript
so i wrote it before that had maternity
leave and then came back and started
doing edits so it's been a
it's been a it's been a long cycle but
it's fantastic that it's out
and it's already people are already
loving it so i'm so thankful the
response has been
uh right out of the gate really strong
and of course you're working uh
what book launch week means is you're
working 16 hour days doing uh
what a couple of hundred media hits in
the in the uh
in about a four about a three day period
of time here yes yeah
here at the office including in the
morning yesterday rachel ray and
tomorrow morning good morning america
yes
wednesday morning for those of you
listening on different times but
wednesday morning good morning america
be watching
uh current hit time is around 8 23 if i
remember right
yes so be watching for that but also in
your local television stations you're
hitting every major market
uh we can do all of that uh from our
studios here with fiber these days
and uh should just make it easier than
being on a bus
it does i mean i miss book tour when
you're usually
when we launch books we're out for about
two and a half weeks traveling and going
to each city and doing book signings at
night media during the day
and i love that i think it's so fun so
the fact that it got cancelled because
of
covid19 i was like oh man it's like one
of those things that was canceled that
you just i mean everyone has that in
their personal life you're like oh i
just hate that i don't get to do that so
well you don't get to see the people and
you enjoy and i enjoy
going out to eat at all the different
restaurants in every city oh there it is
no and there it is now we got it i enjoy
all of that i really do
and i mean obviously yes meeting the
people and being in the studios and
doing it all but uh but this is
fantastic yes with three little kids at
home
it's worked out it's great so i'm able
to be home in my bed at night but here
uh in the day yeah helping promote it
because it's been interesting even this
morning
i did about 10 different cities in a row
and
almost half of them were like yeah well
our entire crew has been talking about
it because
you know they talk about the seven
tendencies in the book and the money
fears and your money personality and how
you grew up and they all are
connecting it to themselves so it's fun
that it already has connected
even just in a brief discussion about it
well and since we can't do like real
launch parties and real book signings we
are going to do a virtual
launch party tomorrow night january the
6th wednesday night
and another one on thursday night at 6
00 p.m is that right both of us yes
correct 7 p.m
and uh okay i've got six on my notes so
i don't know what's right
but um do we know what's right is it
seven or six
okay i'm almost positive at seven okay i
think i'm not great details i'm a free
spirit
so i might be late to myself this other
note says this other note says seven so
i'm pretty sure it's got one of each but
you find out it's on rachelcruise.com
yeah i'm pretty sure it's seven so
virtual launch party rachelcruze.com you
can ask her your money questions join
the virtual launch party
it's at seven seven p.m central time
yes both now we have clarification on
that so um
i will fix that i was right man you were
right
this paper was right this one was wrong
which is kind of surprising that's it
well no it's not you've got a couple
things up in the air and you're
memorizing all of it it's perfect so
there you go
7 p.m wednesday night and thursday night
january 6th and 7th the virtual launch
party you can go to rachelcruise.com
to ask her your money questions okay so
know yourself know your money the thing
that is resonating
is the way you grew up with money and
the money tendencies the seven money
tendencies are you
scarcity or are you abundance right
right yeah so the whole book
really was this deep dive into
understanding why
so we talk about the how to we've been
doing that for decades now right how to
get out of debt how to budget how to
invest how to give
and so i started really this process
this was a few years ago where i
remember diving into like the enneagram
and learning about myself i was doing
some counseling i read the book the
birth order because i'm a middle child
like
seeing just how all of how you were
raised in your current environment
affects
how you see the world and your
personality and i thought man what how
does that relate to our money
and it felt like this black hole of
content because i was like there is so
much here of
why we view money the way we view it why
we handle it why it's our habits and our
person like all of that
and when you can start to get a grasp on
that then you can start making effective
change you can actually start to say
okay i can change my money habits
because i know
when i'm being unhealthy in a certain
place or where that's a great habit and
i can magnify that
so in turn it helps you win with money
so much faster and gives you
a lasting financial piece as an example
if you understand that you uh
are scarcity versus abundance yes what
does that do for you well so the seven
money tendencies neither one's right or
wrong
uh on the on the extremes of these that
can be unhealthy so
for if you're an abundance mindset
person you see the glass half full
there's always more opportunity always
more money to be made
uh but the the bad side the unhealthy of
that is you can be unwise you can make
unwise decisions because i think you can
out earn your stupidity yes 100
you think oh it'll be fine i'll figure
it out yeah me as you raise your hands
i've always been able to make more money
yeah so that's an abundance mindset so a
more scarcity mindset you see the glass
half empty and again
if that's your natural bent that's not a
bad thing you're a little bit more
cautious a little bit more aware
but the unhealthy side of that when you
go to the extreme you end up making
decisions out of fear you hold your
money tightly because you feel like it's
finite
you don't want to let go so you're not
extremely generous you don't spend
it in joy so that's unhealthy so these
these um
these tendencies to be able to pinpoint
okay i can know when i'm going to those
unhealthy extremes
uh so another uh tendency is
status versus security and this is why
you want money some people
want money for security they want to
feel like they are taken care of that
they're
safe i feel good now again
the unhealthy side of that is they end
up just stalking away
and money ultimately is not your
security like there's a level of faith
in our life and
all of that so that can be an unhealthy
uh side
status not bad and i'm more of this
i want i want money so that i can enjoy
it so that i can buy things i can
experience things
i will budget so that i can spend like
that's where i get my motivation now the
unhealthy side of that is that
your identity ends up being the things
that you buy materialistic or your
accomplishments that becomes who you are
and that's not healthy
so that's an interesting one to figure
out why do people want to win with money
and we started this
years ago i identified people doing
budgets and you included that in the
seven tendencies of being a nerd or free
spirit and you guys have been through
financial peace university 20 years ago
heard all that yep
and again the same thing the nerd can be
too uptight too detailed clamp down the
free spirit
free spirit's there for you to have fun
and free spirits have to be mature
enough
to live on a plan so that they get to do
more free spiriting
that kind of stuff know yourself know
your money you can go to daveramsey.com
rachelcruise.com discover
why you handle money the way you do
and what to do about it it is on sale
officially
today it's book launch day this is the
dave ramsey show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm
is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Applause]
so
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're answering
questions about life and money on the
book launch day for know yourself know
your money by rachel soon to be her
latest number one danielle is with us in
richmond virginia hi danielle welcome to
the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my daughter is three and she was
diagnosed with leukemia
at the beginning of april so we pause
our vet snowball and my question is
at what point do you start it up again
she still has about two years left of
treatment
and as we we just weren't sure when to
start it up again
yeah takes my breath away um
how's she doing she's doing very well
um treatment's moving right along where
we need to be
kids are resilient that's what i have to
say they're
the kids are amazing when they fight
this um it's the rest of us that fall
apart
[Laughter]
oh my gosh uh uh
well you got a long slog here
and job one is beat cancer right
yes we don't have any other jobs to do
that's our only job
yes anything else is like a side gig
agreed yes including including
restarting your debt snowball
including all that kind of stuff so
let's just say that
uh number one it doesn't matter
when you restart it what does matter is
that you do everything
you can with money time effort spirit
prayer everything
and you pour everything into this job
one okay
and it's all consuming and it should be
and it's what you do so let's do that
now you are kind of past the fog of some
of that and you're kind of in the rhythm
of the treatments given that it's coming
up on
the first year right yes
and so if things are in a wacky world
that you're in
somewhat normalized the rhythm is
somewhat predictable
and you have extra cash beyond what you
need to fight cancer
and you want to start back a little bit
that's okay
i would not expect quote unquote gazelle
intensity because i would not expect
that of myself
were i facing this
but by the way it's perfectly okay with
me
from from the using the principles that
we teach
to do absolutely nothing towards your
money except
pile up cash any extra cash you have you
need to not
go crazy and go into a bunch of debt
with quote grief spending or something
like that or
or justification or rationalization well
we can do anything we want to do because
we've got this problem
no because you got to go back and clean
up the mess you make and so don't make a
mess right
but but pile up cash that would have
gone towards debt
and if you want to just wait until the
three years has gone and then restart
that's okay with me too
rachel what are your thoughts well
danielle's curious how much how much
debt do you guys have
all right we've paid off the cars we
never got credit cards so the only thing
we have under student loans which is
42 000 yeah household income is what
65 i believe yeah yeah i mean my
husband's active duty military so it's
been a blessing having a steady paycheck
during this
for sure yeah i mean i'm i mean i have a
three-year-old danielle so i can't even
imagine
like it kind of just makes me tear up
talking to you because i'm like i can't
even go there emotionally because it's
so terrible so
i mean if that was me i think everything
else in my life just pauses
um and i focus on on my on my child
so i'm yeah i'm with i'm with dave right
there where
if you choose to do nothing for two
years until treatment's over
100 okay um because yeah that is your
number one thing
but if you had forty two thousand
dollars in savings when that happened
the you know at the end of three years
that wouldn't be that be the way to do
it
okay in other words it's not you're not
gonna
again sli slide over and misbehave
but you're just not gonna pay down on
the debt and have no not enough money in
savings to deal with something because
you might need to jump on an airplane
and do something right
um and uh to get a treatment it's almost
like they know when someone's pregnant
we always say just pause
for nine months wait till the baby's
here wait till everyone's good and
healthy
and then whatever money you've saved
then you can put towards
the debt you can almost think of it like
that like a two-year pause we're gonna
just pile up cash
okay when everything's good and the
treatment and everything is done
and she's healthy on the other side
whatever you've piled up
of savings then you can just throw at
the debt yeah but don't go buy
a new car no right and say that that's
okay because of the mess you're in you
made a bigger mess
and people do that sometimes they they
um
well money is a coping mechanism yeah
you push you you push your spending over
like food's a coping mechanism you put
your spending over to deal with the
stress of this
and the grief of having to fight this
and all of that so yeah that that's just
guard against that and that's what a lot
of people dealt with
not this specifically but in 2020 the 43
of americans spent because of
stress and anxiety during the pandemic
so you see the rise
of spending to feel good is what is what
you're talking about
and 44 can't fit in anything but their
sweatpants i just made that up but
yeah i mean there's that too so
[Music]
[Laughter]
but i mean yeah food and money or coping
mechanisms yeah
and alcohol i mean there's a lot there's
a lot of magnets alcohol sales are
through the roof they're almost as good
as plexiglas sales
okay so anyway so so danielle the banner
statement is making sure your spending
is not just to cope but just for you
guys to save pause take care of that
baby
owen is with us in newark new jersey hey
owen your question for rachel
and me well congratulations rachel on
your book thank you owen i'm graduating
you're awesome i'm graduating in may and
i have a very generous job lined up
and i was wondering how you would advise
a 22 year old who's transitioning from
being a college student
making a full-time income um of course
i'm going to get my emergency fund set
up and using my
full 401k match but uh there's going
through leftover income
and i don't want to waste it oh and do
you have any debt
currently when you graduate you have
student loans or credit card debt
no i was fortunate enough to get a nice
dollar sister oh awesome amazing
uh i mean yeah i mean i would say oh and
number one the fact you're asking the
question
is encouraging because you're gonna be
starting this process at 22 which is
incredible
so yeah i mean it's exactly what you
just said just making having some cash
on the side for an emergency fund three
to six months of expenses
and then looking into retirement and
funding that 15
from there and then and even in the
process if
i wouldn't buy a house right out of
college but having some savings if you
want to save up for a down payment on a
home because you know that may be coming
later in life
doing that too how much are you going to
be making at your new job
uh 157 plus a little stock good night
owen what are you doing
what's your duet software
software development yes yeah software
engineering
okay wow nice owen that's a great very
impressive young man
that's a very good very impressive out
of college to give you an idea i made
exactly 10 when i came out of college or
what you're going to be making when you
come out
34. so
yeah i think you have a bright future
sir you're going to be okay don't screw
it up
wow got a free ride somehow and comes
out
smart i'm scared
yeah we didn't have any of those either
hey hey hey no i'm talking about me too
oh and that's awesome way to go owen way
to go yeah just save up some money pile
up some money and get ready for your
home purchase above your emergency fund
above 15 of your income i think you
already knew the answer to this
congratulations you are a stud well done
okay so how do you feel
sitting in your chair doing the show how
long have you been doing the show 30
30 years you're getting more young
people calling you
than ever before would you say i think
it's a youtube thing
okay the demographic on youtube do you
feel like a grandfather of america or
you're like these young i used to be
i used to be your peer when you called
and i have evolved into
uh then i went to uncle dave and now i'm
just straight up papa dave yeah
there's no question about it yeah i mean
the the guys calling are younger than my
kids
no if that didn't happen 30 years no
it didn't it was like guys in their 60s
calling you hey
back in the day right no well i mean
still i'll say great america
there's a hope for the future there's a
lot of young people like owens
that's awesome well and i'll bet you
dollars to donuts that he was a youtube
listener probably not an am
probably crazy or something i don't know
he could be you never know but um
there's how it works wow that's awesome
owen
so proud of you sir very well done
salute
you and your parents well done this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
ramsey personality best-selling author
rachel cruz
is my co-host today always
joining me but today is a special day
it's launch day for her new book
know yourself know your money the team
around here
in high gear with marketing and uh
appearances rachel is doing
including good morning america in the
morning be sure you jump on around 8
28 15 you'll see her showing up around
then
know yourself know your money discover
why you handle the money
handle money the way you do and
what to do about it a little inside
baseball for those of you don't know how
things work behind the scenes
you would not believe that putting a
title on a book
and a subtitle on a book is many times
more difficult than writing the book yes
the crap we go through around here to
figure out what how to name
something uh to where when you read it
you go okay that's what the book's about
meaning it the title is prescriptive
and uh and the title doesn't need a
subtitle to explain it but helps explain
it
and not having a subtitle that is in
itself a book
i mean there are so many things violated
by authors and publishers every day
and we spend an inordinate amount of
time emotional energy and
money and creativity studying these
things and testing these things before
they come out
we probably looked at 40 different
titles for this didn't we
yeah it was it was a lot because it was
hard because i'm like it's kind it's not
the psychology of money it's not your
money personality i mean like
what how do you how do you put it in
four words
yeah five words six words i mean it was
it is one of the more difficult things
it's a surprising thing and you know why
one of the reasons is so surprising was
i accidentally
was brilliant with my first book
i had no idea no i really was i mean
financial financial peace is a genius
title
that is a world-class title of a book
but it's just like
who thought i i just jesus i just
dreamed it up and
thank you god for giving me that idea
because i had no marketing team i had no
body to test the title i just said you
know what that's what it's about it's
about having peace in your finances and
everybody will understand that and it
works so well and every book after then
has been a
labor to try to put a my worst title
is more than enough that sucks
i really you know and it's the worst
selling book i've ever done too
you think it's because the title yeah
well no the book is awesome
no there's multiple reasons i won't get
into all of them but some are my fault
some of them might be the publisher
but the uh uh but the book itself is
awesome once you get into it but
very few people have read it there you
go okay so it's just
there you go it's a process you guys
morgan is with us in jacksonville
florida hi morgan welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave and rachel um so i just had a
christian
um me and my husband we bought a house
eight months ago out in the country it's
like a it's a really beautiful house
it's on a
on a small river on a small river third
acre or a third
yeah third of an acre but um we thought
it was a manufactured home and it's
actually a modular home
um but you really can't tell because it
has like a big porch and like
a detached garage and things and so
we've been like putting a lot into it
because we like kind of want to
be like our family home and um but we
recently
have just discovered that it has like
two very very large
problems and one of them one of them
it's not technically a problem yet but
it will be a problem
um in the next few years and so we were
we were trying to see if we would we
should stay in this house or if it would
be wise to like stay in this house for
as long as we
wanted we were hope we were wanting to
stay for like seven to nine years until
we like outgrow the house
but um we were just wondering if like i
don't know if we could get the money
back
if we did fix the larger issue and so i
was just
wondering if you guys would advise that
we should
leave the house what are the two things
what are the two things what do they
cost and what'd you pay for the house
um so we paid 156 for the house um
and one of the problems we recently
discovered that there was water damage
in the mudroom and so we that's like the
urgent problem that we currently are
having to go back in
our baby steps into our emergency fund
to fix because there's like mold and
rotting wood on in the floor and um but
what's that going to cost what's that
going to cost i'm hoping under 10
000. okay so what's the other problem
um it's a foundation problem we've
recently had a lot of cracking
in the house there was already a lot of
cracking but the cracks have gotten
wider just in the eight months that
we've been here
and so um the guy that we had come out
today
he said that with doing it at the very
cheapest it was probably going to be 15
000
but he couldn't even do it and so the
people that could do it
are a much more expensive
um company so they would
they would probably be more around
twenty thousand six he said
he said that he did he did say that yeah
okay so you don't have enough
information yet
your feelings are hurt that your new
house is broken
okay yeah you don't have a financial
catastrophe
okay fix the mud room get five bids
and spend six months studying the
foundation before you make a decision on
it
foundation repair is full of
the people that do it are uh there are
groups of people that do it that are
wonderful people
and there's a bunch of jack legs that
just make up crap
as they're going and i think that's who
you met today
well he was he yeah i know he was nice
but you
he also didn't know how to fix it he
also gave you an estimate about what
another person's company would charge
you
which is making up crap he pulled that
out of his ear
he had to call the the other company we
called the other company
and we called the manufacturer of the
house and they were saying that we would
only because it has like this mental
uh like this protection underneath this
insulated protection in the crawl
space he said that we would um like
he said we'd have to get a specific kind
of foundation specialist which
there's a it's like a really small town
we live in and so the closest one
um had you've had three conversations
and you're ready to move okay don't do
it
fix the mud room and spend six months
studying the foundation
getting more bids talking to more people
finding more ways to fix it
there's a lot of things you can do to
foundations
there's more than just one possible fix
and there's certainly more
than just one possible company even if
you're
quote unquote out in the country you can
pay people five thousand dollars and
they will come out in the country
and fix this for seven i don't know i'm
making this up but you don't know this
yet
and so you've got to gather more
information when's the point that you
would say
no yeah you need to move that it's not
worth fixing because in order to
sell it you got to fix it you have to
disclose yeah you have to fix it or you
have to disclose it right
one of the two i mean if it was an 80
000 repair on this
i'd have a lawsuit against the seller
for not disclosing
you know at that point the people that
sold it to them and the real estate
agents are involved and the
home inspector that missed the
inspection which by the way never buy a
home
without an inspection and these are the
reasons right here
so you don't get your heart broken on
the thing that you thought you were
going to be in love with for nine years
and now you find out you got mud room
with mold and a crack
foundation so foundations in
different states and in different
regions are sitting on different kinds
of soil
and there's all kinds of different
situations um
with you being in florida you're
probably sitting on some version of sand
and um so you know it's probably some
version of slab
and i don't know you gotta you just have
to look at it and get in there and
figure out what they do
in tennessee the fix would be different
than it is in florida
but i have owned over 2000 pieces of
real estate i did rehabs for a living
for a decade and one thing i know
is is that it's guys working on houses
are kind of like doctors
they are practicing that's why they call
it a medical practice
they're making crap up as they go and
they proved that during covid
they didn't know what they were doing
and so they just did stuff
and so they're practicing medicine
and some of them are better at
practicing than others
and none of them apparently are good at
math
but the same thing is true of
foundational people they're practicing
they're trying to figure it out and
they're looking at three little cracks
and trying to figure out how to fix your
house you need more information before
you shut the economy down
that's what you're going to do this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this coming tuesday night we want to do
something to help you guys kick off your
new year right with money after last
year a lot of people will raise their
hand and say
i need to reset i need to restart
i need to get get a do-over i need a
whiteboard i need to start fresh and i'm
ready to set go
so we are doing a reset live stream
live from lifechurch.tv in oklahoma city
this coming tuesday night at
7 p.m central time that's january the
12th at 7 pm central time
it is free it will be me
rachel cruz chris hogan and pastor craig
groschel and uh rachel will be covering
some of the material from know yourself
know your money
i will of course be talking with chris
chris hogan and i'll be talking about
how to walk you through the baby steps
and how to do your reset
and pastor craig has an incredible he's
a world-class communicator
uh talk on discipline that i have
loved and i asked him to do it it's
really good and so
um looking forward to this it's gonna be
an absolutely incredible night
it is completely free how do i watch you
say dave
well here's the deal you text the word
reset
233 789
text reset to seven 33
nine and it is a free did i mention it's
free
live stream this tuesday night that's
gonna be fun oh it's me great
i think that the content is
really spot on for where we are right
early 2021
we did message of hope we did that we
did a couple of things
in 2020 to kind of set the course and i
think that this
event it is going to launch people into
a new year
to gain a new control over specifically
their money but also their life like you
said the discipline
um talk from craig can be applied in
every aspect of your life
but really getting your money under
control this year i think it's something
that
so many people feel i wonder i'm sure
stats will come out later in the year
resolutions money's always in the top
three but i wonder if it even rises to
the top of the top
because of 2020. i'm sure i mean after
that dumpster fire
everybody's got to re-look this right
and go thank god that's in my rearview
mirror now i got to fix the mess that i
made
or maybe that was just my wake up call
or maybe i was doing pretty good but i
want to do even better because i never
want to be
vulnerable again i don't want my family
to be
vulnerable financially because we're
living deeply in debt and no money
and we don't have any wealth and wealth
is not valuable except what it does
that's the only thing it does it gives
you margin it gives you a pad
between the the crazy things in life you
can't protect everything you're still
going to die you know there's lots of
things
people still get sick you can't control
any of that that's not the point but
wealth doesn't buy any of that anyway
all it does is give you the ability to
manage the process
you know as you're going through and it
gives you lots of options to do things
and if you need to buy an airline ticket
to go visit a sick relative you don't
have to think about it because you've
got the
money but when when you need to buy an
airline ticket to visit a sick relative
and you're broke now you have two crises
a financial crisis and a sick relative
and so you've got all of these things
going on and
this is your chance to reset and not
leave yourself
vulnerable again text the word reset to
33789 it's this coming tuesday night we
want you there
there's already over 65 000 people
registered to watch this
it is going to be the largest live
stream we've ever done
it's uh it's going to be probably 150
000 people by the time
the uh the by the time the numbers are
in next tuesday
so we're really really excited about
this all right
jake is with us jake's in portland
oregon hi jake welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave and rachel thanks for taking my
call sure what's up hi
i have a question so this year i became
debt free i followed the baby steps and
i'm debt free and i've got approximately
70 000
in the bank with um that's including my
emergency fund
my issue is that my mother and my
older brother with mental disabilities
live in a
dilapidated house that's owned by my
grandpa
she's been living in it for 17 years
without paying any kind of rent and he
refuses to maintain it at all so it
hasn't had anything
done to it in 17 years it's currently
falling apart
it has mold in it it has holes in the
wall
i mean it's it's pretty bad i've been
running the numbers and i think it's
going to be about a hundred thousand
dollar remodel
so my question is should i buy this
house from my grandpa
and then put the money in out of my
savings into doing the remodel
even though i may not have enough right
now or do i
say you know forget this house and then
move them out into a different house
because this is an unhealthy situation
and i'm not sure how to fix this
situation at the moment
what do you make of here i make about
110 000.
how old are you 32.
you're an extraordinary young man
willing and able
to do this for your mom and your brother
with disabilities
well done um so
what i always think of is what is the
most efficient way
financially and time-wise to accomplish
the goal
and the goal is for your mother and
brother to have a place to live that's
not
mold infested and falling through
okay so um
now there's two things you can do uh
what would i do if i were in your shoes
is your home paid for
i actually sold my home at the beginning
of the pandemic and now i'm renting
really cheap so i lowered my living
expenses by 75 percent by renting
[Music]
so at some point again you will buy and
move on with your life in that part of
your world
are you single yes sir okay
all right um i would do a two-step
procedure if i were in your shoes
one is i would move them out into an
inexpensive rental immediately
and just pay for it
you make a ton of money and you have a
ton of money
in comparison to them and by the way a
few months of rent
is a lot less than buying a house for a
hundred thousand dollars
or remodeling a house for a hundred
thousand dollars you can rent a long
long time for a hundred grand
right yes sir okay so we don't do this
forever but my point is use of your cash
and burning of your cash if you rented
them a property
for two years what could you rent it for
uh yeah approximately around there it
would be about 1300 a month i believe
okay all right and so um
you know i'm probably going to cheat on
that and say let's let's try to they're
living in
a dump now let's try to make it a
thousand that's twelve thousand if you
did for two years that'd be twenty four
thousand dollars right
yes sir okay and that's a sizable
upgrade from where they are
during that two years save money
and buy an inexpensive property that is
way nicer than they're living in now
and pay cash for it and just let them
live there
okay and i think you could probably pull
that off in two years couldn't you
yes sir i think so and then you would
move on with you buying a house for you
later
do not move in with them and do not
combine your household
do not combine your households in order
to make this financial goal happen
okay that is not what i'm suggesting
okay
but uh where do they live uh they live
down in arkansas
where in arkansas uh northwest arkansas
around fayetteville
yeah okay so you can buy
you can uh 4x of their living situation
for uh 75 grand to 100 grand can't you
yes sir okay yeah i mean that's a palace
compared to where they're living
definitely yeah and just pay cash for it
and then all you gotta do is make sure
that the taxes are paid the insurance is
kept
up and um that your mom keeps the
utilities paid which she's probably
doing now right
um barely she's got a business that
wasn't
doing very well before the pandemic and
now it's just stuck a knife in it so
it's going to go out of business so she
has zero income at this point
yeah how old is she uh in her early 50s
time for her to have another income yes
sir and that's uh
something we talked about but if she
fights against it
yeah well sitting on your butt is not
going to work it's you know this is an
option so
you can be generous to a point but we're
not going to be an enabler either
so um you're a fine young man that's how
i would do it i would rent something
for uh probably less than a thousand now
that i've learned a little more
and uh yeah and then some you know good
area but it's an expensive area yeah and
so and good people uh but i i would
uh yeah rent something inexpensively for
a couple years pile up some cash pay
cash for it and then move on with your
financial goals
but also a part of that is she needs to
be able to maintain it
and she needs to be able to uh get her
career moving again she is in her early
50s and this is
a requirement of the future of her life
she has a 90
year life expectancy that's a long time
from 52.
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice hi i'm
dave ramsey your host rachel cruz ramsey
personality is my co-host today
we're taking your calls about life and
money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five happy
new year america
it is time for you to get a fresh start
on your money and part of what we're
doing at ramsey to help you do that is
we're launching a brand new book today
by rachel cruz
it has been over a year in the making
know yourself
know your money is officially on sale
another number one i'm pretty sure we
haven't gotten the numbers in yet we
won't for a week but i'm pretty
confident of that
um congratulations thank you
it's exciting it's weird it's always
weird with book launch day because
again it's a project you worked on for
so long and now it's out there
and yeah my hope is people love it and
it helps them i mean it's kind of a new
way of looking
at the way you handle money and it's
really dives into your decision making
how you're wired
why you do the things you do and it's
it's really exciting
i'm looking down the back of it and i
knew we did this but now that i look at
it in this setting it's pretty
impressive the endorsements on the back
of the book are marcus buckingham
uh dr henry cloud candace cam cameron
puree is that is that pronounced
yeah and well i mean you loved her back
when she was on full house when you were
a little kid so there you go
bobby bones of course our buddy here in
nashville that's a
country music um icon uh
radio radio icon i guess i should say
christine kane another icon and the
minimalists
so uh and apparently their new
uh netflix thing may have dropped
because i'm getting some comments on
social about my appearance on it
yeah i think it's out so i think it must
have hit so uh those guys are great
the minimalist oh they're awesome
awesome awesome and they obviously love
you
quite a wonderful quote i did their
minimalist challenge
um i write about it in the book but it's
fascinating because it's all about
understanding so
one of the tendencies is do you do are
you quality or quantity
when we talked about the seven
tendencies earlier in the show and so i
am quantity like i would rather have
inexpensive things but have
20 pairs of earrings versus like one
nice pair of
earrings so that's always been my bent
it's always kind of how i've shopped
and i just i just had so much crap like
i have so much stuff
so they're minimalist challenges you
take a calendar month and every day
whatever the date
is you use that number to give away
something sell something throw it out
so if it's the 14th of the month there's
14 items around your house you got to
get and get rid of
and you do it every and it's number one
is so great just minimizing your life
and just
getting stuck i mean oh i can't remember
the number now
i can't do the math that quick but yeah
i write about in the book but it's
amazing so
it's they're they're awesome and i
totally believe
in their message because i mean it's and
again so much of even this book
there's that level of not letting stuff
absolutely consume you and i think
that's a level
and a reason people just go into debt
and i think a lot of life
problems masquerade themselves as money
problems so you look at a debt problem
and it can either be through consumption
of things you can't afford it there can
be a contentment issue there could be a
planning issue you're not planning your
money well so you're using debt i mean
all of it it all fits together in this
huge cycle and i love kind of connecting
all the dots
know yourself know your money so one of
the tendencies is quantity versus
quality
and as you say in the book neither one
are bad
neither one or good it's only when you
go to the extreme of one of them that's
right yep
so the moderation is ideal right you
kind of have i knew a lady in our
neighborhood who would buy coupon stuff
and she had like 7 000 jars of peanut
butter in her basement not quite but it
felt like it when i was a little kid
like enough jars of peanut butter to
last you into the millennial right and i
was a little kid so a long time ago
so i mean that could even be a scarcity
mindset too of like this fear of oh gosh
oh gosh
that's almost like a prepper before
there were preppers but yeah
but our coupon are gone crazy i don't
know but i mean that's a
that's a yeah it's almost i mean that's
like it is hoarding
it's a borderline it was real organized
so it wasn't hurting but um
but yeah the uh she had the organizer
lady come before she was born too
but but yeah
and one of them one of the spectrums
that you
that we gauge ourselves on in the book
is experiences
versus things things yeah so would you
rather spend money on an experience
or a thing would you rather go out to
eat or would you rather have a nice
shirt right exactly and where and where
the tension
can be in this it's not as much as the
extremes but relational tension comes up
a lot in this so married couples when
you value spending money on different
things
or different ways that's where conflict
can come in you are experienced off the
chain
yes and winston is not no he's all
things i mean
even when we were first married it was
like our first
i think it really was our first year of
marriage we'd go out to dinner
and he'd always get water and i was like
please just get a glass of wine or get a
coke like i don't care just like
let's get a drink and enjoy and he's
like babe i'm good
i'm good with my water because i can
take my seven dollars
and go buy a two liter coke or a bottle
of wine or whatever it is
and and for a while it just always
frustrated me a little bit i was like
man just like enjoy he's like i'm good
he genuinely was so good he's like
i'm good and then as i was like flushing
out this book thing about swords i was
like that's it like that's a prime
example
of he just doesn't really value
experiences he enjoys it and it's fine
but where i want the whole elaborate
thing
he's like no i'm good and yeah it just
makes me laugh even our christmas lists
our christmas lists are 100 different
i'm like i want a small gift card i want
a zoo membership with the kids like
i want all this experience and he's like
i want alexa light bulbs so i can turn
on my
living room when i can say alexa
yeah like that's winston he's like no
because for him it's like i value if i
work hard and make money
no alexa light bulbs were a thing oh
yeah lord jesus no we won't get to the
conspiracies of everything but
anyways so i'm like yeah like that is
that is a real thing so when you budget
and sit down as a couple
especially if you're getting out of debt
and you're having to make sacrifices
like
where you're putting your money there
can be tension so there's just the
warning flag of that that that's where
conversations can come into play
saver versus suspender yes that's a
tendency
and again extremes not good you don't
want to be a hoarder on the saver side
you don't want to spend everything you
make on that side but being able to name
it so are you experienced or things
i'm experienced your experience okay
yeah are you quality or quantity
or your quantity or quality your quality
yeah
yeah like i don't i don't really care um
you know you buy a lot i do you're a
spender
i'm k i'm a spender i'm definitely a
spender but i uh but it's not quite but
i
yeah i'm not gonna if i go to buy a
whatever i want the best one a pair of
boots
you don't need like yeah i don't have no
desire to have six pairs of boots i
really have
one really good pair that i can wear the
rest of my life yeah get some good
cowboy boots yeah that's
i've got a pair that i've had for 20
years yeah there you go that's it
that's it we'll probably have them for
20 more but and they look great
so shut up yeah sure sure they do
sure they did polish up oh old-fashioned
thing we used to polish our shoes not
throw them away
but yeah so know yourself know your
money rachel cruz's new book is
out on the stand you can find it
anywhere great books are sold
amazon daveramsey.comrachelcruise.com
target barnes noble books noble walmart
uh you can find it it's out there good
morning america in the morning be
watching at around 8 15 8 20 rachel will
be on talking about the book so check it
out
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior
shutters with easy online ordering free
shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit go to
blinds.com and take advantage of this
week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host
today here on the air it's book launch
day for her new book know yourself know
your money
there is a virtual launch party
january 6 that would be tomorrow night
for most of you in january 7th
thursday night wednesday and thursday
night two different virtual launch
parties
at 7 pm central time
and that's it rachelcruze.com you can go
live and ask her your money questions
and participate in this book launch if
you'd like we'd love to have you
again just go to rachelcruise.com and
sign up for the virtual launch party
wednesday or thursday night this week at
7
pm jesse is with us in grand rapids
michigan hi jesse welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi thank you so much for everything
you've taught
we are just having a lot of fun my
husband and i um
built our dream house four years ago we
went into the steps
baby steps about 15 months ago and i
didn't think we'd get through them as
fast as we did but we're already on step
six
wow great yeah we feel good so i'm kind
of a nerd i punch the numbers every day
and i've gotten a little addicted to
this
mortgage payoff calculator good and
so you know i arbitrarily picked a
number to save for our two kids
for college they're currently ages six
and eight
and we're putting 150 for each kid into
an esa
but i'm seeing if i you know i don't
want to borrow and rearrange these steps
because i know that's my pet peeve when
people call in
but can i or should i lower
that dollar amount in the esa in order
to put more on the house
or should i just leave that be just stay
calm and just pay it off we're currently
saving cash for a barn
so anything extra right now we're
putting aside to build our barn
i'm just wondering your thoughts
how much money do you guys have saved in
the usa so far
each in the esa are only about i'd say
four grand for each
kid what's your household income
about 200 000. and what do you owe in
your home
217. what's the barn cost
uh we estimated about 60 and we have
we have 25 000 saves currently okay
so um 200 a month is 2400
a year
that doesn't really move the needle on
barns or houses
okay i mean you can if you want
but it's not really going to move it
that much what's moving it
what has moved you along so fast is your
all's attention to detail and your
intentionality
i mean you have this wonderful income
and you're using it to accomplish your
financial goals
way to go touchdown so
technically to answer your question
about rearranging the baby steps you
know we just say baby step five saving
for college we don't say
how much because it ranges so much
whether you've got little kids older
kids
what your household income is all that
kind of junk as to what you can put in
and still accomplish your baby and still
be putting something towards baby step
six
but um if you wanted to back it down to
fifty dollars it's okay
but my point is it's 2400 a year
yeah i just like i said that mortgage
calculator on your website is
amazing and you can see what an extra
you know we're putting we're paying
eight hundred dollars extra a month on
our mortgage currently
and giving for a bargain yeah yeah so
when you get the barn finished
so you're estimating if you stay on your
current path the barn will be done and
the house will be paid for when
um 2000 in about
six years five years five years yeah
that's what i was going to guess
okay so doing this change doing this
changes it four months
okay okay
i made that up but i'm not far off it
might be it might be five months it
might be three months
the dave calculator it's 20 but it's
2400 i mean over five years so that's
ten thousand dollars that's right
yeah it's not it's not going to move the
needle on it's not gonna change
if it changed your payoff on your home
by five years
or three years or something like that
yeah maybe but when it changes it by a
month or two months
or three months now i wouldn't do it
jesse you're what's your husband what's
he saying is he is he on board too or is
he kind of like oh we can kind of chill
a little bit
oh yeah no he he started listening to
dave in a
am radio van when he was a landscaper
when he started dating
so he's he's so chill and he just says
you know
the the growth that we'll gain in the
esa
is better than the low interest on the
mortgage
if the growth on the esa account yeah
and keep it
going yeah so the technical baby step
answer is you can do either
i probably would stay with your current
plan because i don't think it moves the
needle that much to change it
and i think you'll be glad you put money
into the usa i'm really not even worried
about the growth on the essay versus a
mortgage bound
you know that that you know that would
lend you to
say i'm going to load the essay up i'm
going to put even more in
but right now you you're touching the
base which is what you want to do on
baby step five you want to do something
towards kids college and then you moved
on to do the other stuff so
yeah and she's she's an example of the
nerd
not quite on the extreme because i don't
think you're unhealthy by any means in
that sense but
she's running numbers she's calculating
it's almost like you want to be gazelle
intense through these baby steps and
you're not supposed to you're supposed
to back off so the fact you guys are
saving for a barn i think it's awesome
like yeah you can just yeah take a
breath even though you're crunching the
numbers and you're seeing
the difference of what you're paying
just an interest even for two years of a
home having a mortgage versus not i
think all that's awesome that you're
feeling what a free spirit doesn't
understand that is that when
nerds like uh jesse and me are running
these numbers that's actually
fun for us well she said i had a lot of
fun we're not we're not we're not
fretting it's not bothering us this is
like what we do
instead of watching netflix we would
rather run numbers on something it's
just more fun
than watching an oprah rerun you know so
uh we actually get
joy out of this i know it's hard for
people to grasp but don't think that way
but
all the nerds are out there going yes
spreadsheets rule yes
and so you know but that's you know
again if you turn it if you turn it all
the way over to where
it becomes an obsession then you're
wrong and she didn't
no she didn't that's why i said she but
i'm saying she's a perfect example of a
nerd
yeah because she's loving it and her
husband's just kind of like hey we got
this
yes yeah and so very very intentional
good job jesse you guys have done a
wonderful job with your money so proud
of you yes i don't think there's oprah
uh anymore oh well probably somewhere
ben is in niagara falls ontario hi ben
how are you
good how are you guys better than i
deserve how can we help
um well i have a bit of a morality
question
for you um so my wife and i
uh are trying to pay off our debt so i
used to be driving
uh like a really cheap junker car
um and now you you always say that like
mama gets a good car right
and um we actually moved over new year's
like christmas new year's
now she lives she lives or she's five
minutes away from her work
and i i have about a 40-minute commute
so i've been driving
like a good car and she's been driving
to junker
um it just it doesn't quite feel right
to me that
that it's that way but i'm worried about
the reliability of the
the junker obviously
[Music]
well i don't know what the law is in
canada but in the united states
it's illegal for you to drive the good
car
i'm kidding it's federal law mama gets a
good car
um does she care ben is she good
or does she want to yeah like she she
doesn't care this is just
like this is just something i i have a
problem with you have like a conviction
that like
oh you feel bad that you're driving the
nice car and your wife's not i think
you're okay
because you guys are only gonna be in
baby step two for how much longer
um about 10 months yeah
why don't you switch every other week
yeah i guess you could do that i don't
know i just made that up i have no idea
but i mean
it has to do with it has to do with how
everybody feels about it and more than
it does the reality
obviously if the stupid car breaks one
of you's got a problem and canada is a
bit
wee bit cold this time of year so um
you know i you know you don't want her
stuck out in the cold
for sure i mean that literally could be
dangerous uh depending on your situation
so but she's five minutes from work i
know it's still complete
no yeah absolutely but the i don't walk
four minutes in that stuff
but the uh um yeah i
you know you can switch out or you know
as long as the thing is not giving you
any trouble
you can drive it i i it's all it's a
joke but it's
um about marriage relationships and
you know understanding sacrifice all the
way through this thing so you're not an
evil guy
either way ben it was a joke but
everybody gets the joke because mama
gets the good car
has a sense of gallantry
gallantry to it civility to it you this
is the dave ramsey show
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help trim
those expenses and make sure your family
is cared for
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars worth of bills
and got close to seventy five percent
discounts chm
shared the rest of the expenses to see
if chm is right for you
and your budget check out
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author
launching a new book today know yourself
know your money discover
why you handle money the way you do and
what to do about it is my co-host today
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question
comes from marilee in nevada
i just paid off my student loans back in
june i just finished the legacy journey
through ramsey plus
and would love to begin a giving
category in my monthly budget and baby
step
three i already give 10 of my income as
a tithe to my local church
but i'm wondering how to create
something a little more
how do i address the numbers is there a
recommendation on how to start giving
past your tithe
do you have any recommendations on which
organizations get started with or even
how to begin
giving i want to do my research before i
give money away if that makes sense
yeah that definitely makes sense um i
mean we we always recommend 10 no matter
where you are in the baby steps and the
whole process the baby steps is to give
a little until you can give a lot
and obviously that a lot huge
explanation point is on baby step seven
once you
have your house paid for you have no
debt kids college is taking care of your
fund your retirement
then you're able to give a ton of your
income because you have a lot of all
your income coming in because you have
no debt
so if you do still want to start giving
a little bit more and you're on baby
step three
i'm i think that's great you can i would
up it maybe just
a few percentage points right now i
really want that emergency fund
for you because once you have that
stability then you're going to be able
to give beyond that 10
for sure so i would recommend just a few
percentage points if you want to right
now
a lot of organizations especially if
they're 501 c 3s they have to
publish their budgets on their website
they have to make that public so you can
go in and look to see
how much of the money coming into the
organization is going to
fees or administration or to the actual
mission of what they're doing you can
look at all of that get a feel
talk about it i mean we take giving
pretty seriously here ramsey what we
talk about is
how much you spend on your retirement
account
and investments is the time you need to
spend on what you're giving i mean you
as a as a believer you have been given
resources and to put it back out to help
people
you want to make sure you're doing it
really efficiently so i think you
researching organizations is smart
um what to get started with i mean
anything you're passionate about
that's i think one of the best things
about our world today is
through the internet social media there
are so many organizations out there
anything you you love and have a heart
for whether it's foster care
or rescuing people out of human
trafficking digging
wells for fresh water in africa helping
the homeless community i mean like
anything that you have a heart for
there's probably an organization that
helps with that mission so just race i
would start there
of what you love yeah and we have chosen
to
give substantially to a few with the
ramsey family foundation not to give
500 to a bazillion different people uh
and spread it out then instead we'd
rather make an impact on a handful
and so if i were in your situation
merely just getting started i would just
pick
one for now there's always
more valid needs and
valid ministries filling those needs
than there is money
free that you have anyway there's always
more
and so you cannot be everywhere and
don't try to be everywhere don't dilute
and don't give a dollar to 500
organizations give 500 to one
or whatever it is you're much better off
to do that your life's much simpler
you won't get as many emails you won't
get invited as many
dinners you get charity fatigue
you do you do you get philanthropy
fatigue
and so you're not going to get there
with all that just keep it real clean
and real simple and do some research
like you're saying you're going to do
and and the way we pick the ministries
that we support we usually know
something about them or they're one
degree of separation
personally one of the ramses do and or
one of us had one of the ramses has a
passion for that category
uh and that's how they end up in the
uh it is a very personal thing with
ramsey family foundation
is how we do it with our giving as a
family uh
and so that's how we would recommend you
do it and i
you know in your case once you finish
baby step three beyond the tithe
if you want to just put a flat a dollar
amount to start and go okay i'm gonna do
500
more a month or whatever just make up a
number i don't care what it is
once you get further along i'd recommend
a percentage
in addition to the 10 on your tithe i
would give another x
percent to other things and that's how
we do it at our house and then no matter
what your income becomes over the years
you've still got your formula and you'll
always be
as you make more you'll always be giving
more automatically and you don't have to
stop and rethink and
all that kind of stuff you can choose to
increase your percentage
if you wanted to later on but that's not
always necessary either
don is with us in grand rapids michigan
hey don welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey how's it going great man how can we
help
a question about um where to put my
retirement fund so
i'm 11 payments away my wife and i are
11 payments away from
being out of our inverted 3b
and then we will have you know we'll be
right into the retirement section of it
so
so if i know your order of retirement
typically but if i max out my raw
401k at work she's a contract bookkeeper
so she can do
a roth um 401k set up for her
and then and then um we could do
roth ira a roth you know iras
right i have an option at work to do a
hsa so i'm wondering if i should do an
hsa
because that's kind of like double tax
incentivized i don't pay taxes going in
or coming out
i know i don't get the growth that i
would but i'm just trying to figure out
how to
best place that last a little bit
the hsa if you use it for medical is a
double
because you take the tax uh deduction
it's not really because you take the tax
deduction and then you don't pay taxes
on it
as you use it and so it's really just
once
and you can get the growth on it uh
check out a company called health
equity that's who we have our hsa
savings with and they have mutual fund
options
i have never used my hsa for health
issues knock on wood
uh consequently i've got a couple
hundred thousand bucks in it
because i just load it up every year
it's yet one more way i can max out
things and if once your home's paid for
um you know you max out everything so
you
you take advantage of everything at your
fingertips and that would be both roths
uh both 401k roths and the hsa
but you get a tax deduction when you go
into the hsa
and you don't pay taxes on it when it
comes out
so that is uh like tax free
use of that money if you use it
for health and you would you use that
before the roth ira no i would use the
roth first because it's growth
it's tax-free growth regardless of what
you use it for
okay that's what i thought you want to
make sure thank you yeah hey thank you
for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five carrie is in dallas texas hi carrie
happy new year hey hey dave happy new
year to you too
and thanks for taking my call sure
what's up um
okay so i'm your problem child
i have lots of credit card debt
um to the tune of 70 000
dollars in credit card debt and yeah
and i um you know purchased
my first home um four years ago almost
and lots of things went wrong
with it but that wasn't all the debt
and um i was given advice from
a friend a year ago to just stop paying
the credit card debt they were all zero
percent and
all the interest rates started i knew
they were about to skyrocket and it was
going to get to the point when i
couldn't even make minimum payments
anymore
and so they just said quit paying just
stop paying and i did try to call
several of them and they weren't willing
to
negotiate anything with me they they
didn't want to talk to me because i was
current on everything yeah
and i had always been of course
so now they're all coming full circle
all right i'll tell you what hold on we
come back from this break we'll get the
rest of your story and see if we can
help you
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five we're
talking with carrie in dallas texas she
ran up seventy thousand dollars in
credit card debt
as the interest rates went from zero to
full-blown as they always do she was
unable to make the payments her friend
suggested she stop
and that's about how far we got in the
conversation what else is going on miss
carrie
yes sir well i started working your
program last month
i reached out and a financial advisor
found me and we've already met she's got
me on a budget
she i've done plastic surgery
i've done all her homework we're meeting
friday again for the new update
things are actually going great i was
going to say you actually
while you're out of control you're
starting to feel in control
i'm more in control i mean that's the
first time i've ever been on a budget
before um i i checked out every dollar
but i think with all this default debt
i felt that you need a budget or y in
ab.com was better for me
i don't because of all this unknown i
don't know i don't know
um
okay yeah it's going to be much better
you just need to run two debt snowballs
is all
okay so i've got all my default debt um
i
i settled or i just settled and paid
two of them i knocked two of the cards
off myself
i got summons for two others through the
same
collection agency or law firm and
i did get a lawyer for the first one and
could kick myself
because i realized i could do it myself
so we he settled for me on the first one
and then
i guess it gave me the template to know
how to do it
so that's what i paid for but i settled
the second one
my question is um on the debt snowball
with those
they're going to be coming at me you
know the different amounts
are coming at me and once it goes i get
a summons i've got to settle those out
no you don't so i don't
okay um they can sue you but they can
show you but in texas they really can't
do anything
well i thought they could get control of
my bank account which would be
not in texas um not in texas i thought
they can't garnish your wages well you
don't need that you don't need to give
them your bank account information
right well i figured i could just switch
bank accounts if that were the case yeah
okay yeah so okay we're not gonna let
their we're not gonna let them create
the emergency we're gonna let you create
it
so all of these this entire 70 000 is in
default
yes sir okay and what other debts do you
have
i only have my um my home
loan which i owe 178
on that are you current i am current i'm
current on everything else
okay the car 707 000. perfect
and 2012
my income is 78 000.
okay and i'm also working i've been
doing ubereats
on the side delivering um and i was able
to pull in 500
last week so way to go um
i'm planning to just keep attacking that
as well
you're inspiring i mean you're inspiring
you made a huge mess
and then when you decided to do
something about it you got a template
from the lawyer you met with a financial
advisor you're working your plan you
picked up an extra job
you made a budget you're doing
everything you are really on fire i'm so
proud of you for what i do
so i am and i just want to keep this
fire and
so as you got as you get little summons
if you want to stop and settle those
that's fine
but if you get one that's a huge one
just let it sit there's one coming up
it's like eight thousand you know 8200
and i told them i spoke with them on the
phone and she wasn't willing to talk to
me
without she wanted me to make a good
faith painter so we're not doing that
today
um i just need to know what you would be
willing to settle for
so i can you know plan for that and be
able to give that to you in a month or
two
and she goes i can't do anything with
you right now
you know then hang up and so i
said listen go ahead and slam the phone
down just for the satisfaction
just for the satisfaction the woman if
she's going to act like she's a test
pilot for a broom
factory treat her that way okay
that was her decision not yours it's not
you know that's all the technique
that's called intimidation and don't
don't let them do that to you you've got
a plan you're on fire you got a system
and so what you're going to do let me
here's what's going to happen okay you
have
three different uh summons and or
collectors coming at you
and you have two thousand dollars
sitting there this is in the future
this is in the future what you're going
to just you're going to mess with every
one of them you're going to go
i got 2 000
who wants it first if you take it
you will get that as a settlement on 8
000 that's behind door number one
if you don't then we're gonna go to door
number two and whichever one of you
calls me back first that's who's getting
this money
i'll get back to the rest of you later
when i got some money and this is a game
show baby
you know and just have some fun with it
right and then you know how to settle it
you've got the template to do that get
it in writing and do not allow them
electronic access to your checking
account
that way they don't know where the flip
it is
right and they don't clean you out on
the rest of your plan
but i did settle on this law firm i did
the two
that i settled on i do not need to pay
online or anything like that or because
it is in a settlement am i safe to just
go online and pay them
or do i need to do the cashier's check
every time
if online means they have your bank
account information
yeah i would think they would do not do
that don't do it okay
okay that's what i thought i just wanted
to ask because they they it once they
have that
if they're unscrupulous and some of them
are they can turn around and clean out
your bank account
okay so you're going to get around to
working with everybody we're not trying
to
ditch them we're not trying to be a
deadbeat we're just not going to be
abused and we're going to play them
against each other until we get through
this
so i need to start with my default debt
snowball
smallest to largest on that i do have
three cards that are current
um i'd knock them out if you can get a
smaller amount
i'd knock them out first
what we tell you is run two debt
snowballs run your current stuff
and pay it off first and let all the
stuff that's in default just sit
and once you've gotten rid of the car
payment and the three active credit
cards
everything but your house then that
gives you more cash flow to deal with
the stuff that's in default that's our
normal routine
you got a few of them coming at you
right now and so if you want to uh
kind of dodge around a little bit head
fake and jump in and out of that
and jump over and knock out one of those
summons that's okay there's not a bad
thing here
okay what i don't want you to do is i
don't want them threatening you
or giving you a hard time or bossing you
around to become the priority
instead you set your priorities you have
power over money for the first time in
your life carrie
use it right you make don't worry about
them taking me to court
then because sometimes you feel pressure
to settle nope
before court we can settle after just as
good
not worried about but i thought that
they would do the full amount plus court
costs
well they will but we're also going to
negotiate that down to 10 cents on the
dollar
okay and they're going to be happy to
get it junk debt it is junk
these aren't junk debt it is junk debt
it's credit cards it's in default it's
called junk debt
okay that's what it is because they all
say they're representing the card that
itself it's still well i don't give a
crap third party
they either own it or they don't but
when they get ready to sell it they're
gonna sell it for a nickel on the dollar
right and so that's what it's worth to
them it's
junk debt it's it's it's almost a year
since they've been paid
they have their probabilities they know
their probability is almost zero it's
five percent chance they're going to get
paid
and the fact that you're working with
them gets them all excited you actually
have a phone number that works
everybody else in their database doesn't
i mean that's
who they're dealing with and so you're
like a unicorn for them they're so happy
to talk to somebody to abuse you
so cara is great carrie carrie you're
doing great listen if you're not in
ramsey plus i'm gonna put you in it hold
on
kelly pick up and make sure you're tied
into that because you were doing
everything right to straighten out your
life
you are doing a full reset which is what
we're doing next tuesday night guys you
don't want to miss out on that it is a
free
live stream event next tuesday night at
seven o'clock
text the word reset to dave ramsey.org
i text it to 33789 reset to
set 33789 and join the new
upcoming live stream next tuesday
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the dave ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice my
co-host today on the air ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author and my daughter rachel cruz
it is book launch day at ramsey which
means we are in high gear all over this
building
lots of media hits lots of things
happening and rachel's doing all of them
the new book know yourself know your
money hit the shelves
today a labor of love for over a year
it takes to put one of these things
together and get it out know yourself
know your money discover
why you handle money the way you do
and what to do about it and rachel our
the
our your seven money tendencies
have been one of the things that people
get their hands around first in the book
it's not the only thing
that you teach about knowing yourself to
know your money but the seven tendencies
are
something that people gravitate to
immediately that and how you grew up
i was going to say the the childhood
money classrooms the tendencies
and even the fears the money fears is
something people relate to a lot yeah
the tendencies are fun just because
there's not a right or wrong
it's just understanding and unpacking
okay here's where i tend to lean
when it comes to my money and it just
gives you a level of awareness and to
say okay
i can now figure out when i'm being
unhealthy in that area when i'm when i'm
okay
and functioning well it gives you kind
of this guidepost
and another level of this which i love
is you start to understand other people
in your life your spouse
your parents your grown kids your
friends it gives you a level of empathy
to say okay they're different than me
when it comes to money not right or
wrong necessarily in these tendencies
but they're different and here's their
view they're looking at money a little
differently than i am
okay and so the seven right quick rattle
them off duet oh it's like the the test
okay nerd versus free spirit spender
versus savor
experience versus things uh quality over
quantity
or verses i shouldn't say over um
abundance versus scarcity safety versus
status
which is why you want money is it safe
to your status and the seventh is on
giving so it's more calculated or
emotional giver which one you are
okay so those are big and then the
childhood classrooms i think that those
are really fun there's four of them
of understanding how you grew up with
money so money was communicated in two
ways
in a household it's communicated
verbally and it's communicated
emotionally so the first money classroom
is the anxious money classroom and this
is where it's verbally closed
and emotionally stressed you can feel in
the air but it's not talked about that's
right so you probably felt tension at
the end of the month when bills were
paid but you didn't know why but tension
around money
classroom number two is the unstable
money classroom so this is where it's
verbally open but emotionally stressed
so if you grew up in this classroom you
heard fights about money your parents
may have fought with extended family
members about money they may have had
the same money fight over and over and
over again
but man it was loud and you knew it was
happening classroom number three is the
unaware money classroom so this is where
it's verbally closed but emotionally
calm
so never talked about but it wasn't an
issue and so your head was probably in
the sands people that grew up in this
classroom
really didn't even think about money
until they were out on their own and
they realized
oh wow i have to learn a lot and i have
a little bit of catching up to do
and then that classroom number four the
last one is the healthiest money
classroom and it's where it's verbally
open
and emotionally calm so you could have
ten dollars in this classroom you could
have 10 million
but it's the matter that it is being
controlled there's a plan in place
it's agreed upon if you're if you have
parents that were still together
and it was just it was calm but it was
also talked about money was talked about
and communicated so that's the fourth
money question that i really want to
push the reader
to move currently to with their family
now
but looking back to your own childhood
to say okay here's how i grew up because
every single one of them come with some
red flags of okay this is
this is an area i'm probably gonna have
to overcome because of my childhood
classroom
yeah and most people don't grow up in
the fourth one
no most don't no i was on a show
yesterday and they had their whole staff
speaking in which was so fun
on the youtube show um and the host grew
up in classroom two
her husband grew up in classroom one uh
that we had one of each of them which
was so interesting one of her producers
was classroom three
and actually one of the girls was
classroom four and
her and i both because that's i would
say i grew up there somewhat classroom
two but i don't remember that
because you said there was a lot of
stress but i was born the year of the
bankruptcy
um but really even that classroom four
just because your parents are smart with
money doesn't it's not a gene
you're not automatically gonna be smart
with money you have to work at it too
and it's that classic larry burkett line
that you spend the first five to seven
years of your marriage
trying to obtain the same standard of
living as your parents but it took your
parents 30 years to get there
so there can be a little bit of a level
of entitlement in that classroom for if
you're not careful so when you're in
classroom four you still have to be
safeguarding that
okay i still have to be making decisions
on my own i still have to be working
hard
and it's up to me and my hard work to
stay in that classroom for
yeah nobody's gonna do it for you you're
what's known as a grown-up now yeah
so yeah so that's a i think it's always
interesting to think about how you grew
up and how it affects you
and what's fascinating too is talking to
people people either
mirror what their parents did
unintentionally or
they have a visceral response and they
do the complete opposite
they do the complete opposite so it's
good just just to be aware
that's true with parenting style that's
true there's a lot of things yeah
yeah the book is know yourself know your
money
by number one best-selling author rachel
cruz this will be her third best seller
uh discover why you handle money the way
you do
and what to do about it know yourself
know your money it is on
bookstore shelves now it is available we
are doing a virtual book tour
a virtual uh launch rachel's doing a
hundred and some-odd media appearances
in about a four-day period of time
including good morning america in the
morning be sure you tune that in at
about 8
20. she'll be on we're doing a virtual
launch party for the book you can join
rachel on january the 6th
that's wednesday and january the 7th
that's
thursday both at 7 p.m at
rachelcruze.com live
just go to rachelcruise.com there'll be
a live feed there
and you can ask her your money questions
so
join her you can sign up for the uh uh
you know for the launch party or be
there january the 6th or 7th
at 7 p.m jump in rachelcrews.com
make it part of your lineup we are also
working to help you get started on your
new year
this year and after 2020 everybody needs
a reset
we need to relook we need to reset
emotionally reset financially
reset everything and if you want to
reset we're doing it this coming tuesday
night
and so lots of things going on all of
this that we've mentioned so far is free
so be sure you check it out we're doing
a reset event live
from oklahoma city rachel cruz chris
hogan
me and pastor craig groschel we'll be
doing it from his church at
lifechurch.tv
rachel will be speaking i'll know
yourself know your money pastor craig on
discipline
chris hogan and i are going to walk you
through the whole reset process and the
steps to take
exactly what to do this is a 100
free live stream it is next tuesday
night january the 12th
at 7 p.m this coming tuesday night
january the 12th at 7 00 p.m
and uh just go to dave ram you can to to
register for the free live stream you do
need to register or it's not going to
happen for you
uh text the word reset two three three
seven eight nine that's three three
seven eight nine and for those of you in
oklahoma city we have a few seats
just a handful uh they're only twenty
dollars and they may be gone by now
uh but of course it's limited because of
distancing and all those kinds of things
to meet the guidelines and stuff
so go to dave ramsey.com events and see
if there's any seats available if you're
in the oklahoma city area we'd love to
have you
come out tuesday january the 12th for
this reset
live stream with four well
four people who are well known for
speaking on these subjects i guess
that's the best way to say it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five
josh is with us josh is in mount vernon
ohio hi josh welcome to the dave ramsey
show
thank you for having me how are you guys
doing today better than we deserve
what's up
i have a question for you guys uh my
wife and i finally finished off
while we're finishing off this friday
for baby step two
yay long did that take
thanks uh 26 months all right good for
you
thanks um so we are moving in and we're
going to be doing our baby step 3 which
is saving you know our
uh three months for our emergency fund
and we also are home owners uh at the
time it wasn't a very wise decision to
purchase a house because we went with a
three percent conventional for a thirty
year
um with a rate of 4.125 percent
we're going to get to a place where we
want to refinance
with rates being what they are around
2.2 to 2.9 percent in our area
and i did not know if it would be best
to go through
getting the full leaf under three months
saved first
and then save up separately yeah because
you don't have enough equity to roll
your closing costs into your refinance
do you
i'd say no if you don't and i don't
think you do
probably because you didn't put enough
down uh so i imagine i would imagine you
can't if you can roll it in you can do
it whenever you want
but if you've got a cash flow you're
closing costs you've got to do that
after your emergency fund is done
okay so let's treat that more like a 3b
it would just be something you purchase
while you're doing four five and six
like if you bought a couch or you
upgraded a car or you did something else
in this case it's closing costs on the
loan
okay but let me tell you how i did that
uh
from a critical thinking standpoint okay
okay if it's not an emergency
it doesn't go before the emergency fund
yeah that's how i put it after the
emergency fund this is this is a good
idea
but it's not an emergency okay so even
if rates fluctuate a little bit which
i'm sure they will
still better than the 4.125 exactly but
definitely
wait until after we're done the number
of times rates move
more than one percent in a four or five
month period of time is almost zero
okay they'll move an eighth a quarter
something like that one direction or
another but they just really don't move
that much that dramatically and you're
gonna be done with that baby step three
pretty quick
well done sir yeah pretty good i mean
but you would say just still
go ahead start baby step four though
like start funding retirement
yeah i mean i'm okay if you did it as a
baby step three b
yeah yeah you know treat it and treat it
like a down payment thing if you want to
but
it's not an emergency right because see
let's let's say you took
five thousand dollars and that's the
only five thousand dollars you had and
you need a refi
and then the transmission goes out on
your car and you lose your job and
there's a pandemic
right you're screwed you know and so
that's how you know that it would have
been a bad idea that's right you run it
through a stress test
yes a hypothetical stress test in your
mind and then you can tell
oh i should have done the emergency fund
first it's more important than saving a
couple points or
or a quarter of a point on my interest
rate by
letting it ride a little bit and that's
the interesting thing about money and
talking about it in this way because
it all it sometimes trumps math right
like the idea of like
well interest rates and they could
fluctuate uh
and it's not a math problem no it's not
it's safeguarding
and continuing to put that strong
financial foundation under you
yeah and you know in that same light
baby steps one
two and three are
you defy everything you you put math
aside
you use the debt snowball you stop your
401k even with a match
you um you know you defy all the
mathematics
but expensive expenses your house is on
fire
yeah you're in debt and you have no
money you are an accident looking for a
place to happen you are normal in
america and normal sucks
78 of americans live paycheck to
paycheck don't live that way
so one through three is the house is on
fire so you don't we don't sit and
discuss
theory when the house on fire you get
your butt out of the house
and you get that you get yourself out of
debt and you get that emergency fund in
place
then when you break through baby step
three that's when you cannot be
gazelle intense anymore and instead of
intense you're intentional
and you start saying okay now we got to
start talking about retirement kit four
we gotta start talking about kids
college five we gotta start talking
about paying off the house six
we gotta upgrade this couch this spring
is sticking me in my butt every time i
sit down here
we gotta get a car it's awful this
beater we've been driving while we were
getting out of debt is horrible
it's time to get a car that doesn't have
a name you know and so on
right and so you you start moving up in
a few things here or there
but you're careful and you're
intentional but you don't have to live
on beans and rice rice and meats oh by
the way that's when you would go on
vacation is only
after baby step three and that's when
you'd go out to eat
is only after baby step three you
shouldn't be going out to eat
i know people think i've lost my dad gum
mine but let me tell you what
when you have a pandemic hit and you
have no freaking money because you've
been in restaurants
you look like a freaking fool because
you are you shouldn't have been going
out to eat
you spent all your dad gum money in a
restaurant yeah and
i don't mind going out to eat i love
going out to you you love going out to
eat the ramsays love
to eat we are we are social animals
but um i'm getting an email to
commercial break from my wife about
going out to eat with another couple you
know i mean
this is normal but it but the problem is
when you're broke
it's foolish because it is not economics
that causes you to eat out it you know
90
of what you spend at a stinking
restaurant is not the food
you could have bought all that food for
10 or 15 at the store and gone home and
cooked it
oh and then made four other meals after
that well yeah the cookie yes
a whole bunch yeah and then got
leftovers in the whole bed god help me
for sharing ramsay but
um her leftovers oh she's still after
all these years
but um like we can't afford home with
food i'm like mom those green beans
there's like no one else now i want to
eat like no one else stop it but um
so yeah but the the the uh the point is
is that you need to treat the first
three like you're in an emergency
like it's on fire and then after that
you're intentional
which means you're thoughtful you're
thinking about okay if i do that i won't
be able to do this
and what's more important would i rather
do my kids college than that couch or
whatever
you know we got to get a couch it's
ridiculous um
family's not been on vacation in five
years we're gonna spend a reasonable
amount and go on do a decent little
vacation of some kind if you could find
a
state that's open and um whatever
right yes you can start you can you know
you you don't
relax to the point that you go back to
stupid land but you relax
to the point that you can enjoy a few of
the creature comforts
again when you're in four five and six
yep but that idea though that it's so
behavior-based especially
baby steps one through three it's not
the math thing like we're talking about
earlier like it really is
it's your behavior and getting ahead and
what ends up happening when you actually
get traction for the first time
in your life and by the way it's not
just a ramsey thing it's not something
dave ramsey or the ramsey organization
came up with
it's a data thing i mean when we study
millionaires the way they became
millionaires was not
math it was managing behavior
none of them were i mean virtually none
of them
90 something percent of them were not
uber sophisticated
had the figure had figured out the idea
of how to get rich at bitcoin or
how to get rich or beat the card game in
vegas or
they weren't day traders or they weren't
they weren't they didn't spend their
whole lives with their nose in a mutual
fund book
they didn't do any of that they just
loaded up their 401k
paid off their house and they really did
not
were not very sophisticated a lot of
them weren't that super efficient with
their math
with the math on the investing they
didn't spend a whole bunch of time
studying it
sometimes they had an investment advisor
sometimes they didn't but they didn't
sit and wring their hands
over the 12 b1 fees in a mutual fund and
they didn't set no load versus load the
great comparison
they didn't go through all that crap
they just put money away get it yes
did it while everybody else is talking
about their freaking theories and
they're broke
these guys go and do it it's a do it
thing it's a behavior thing and
that is what makes people wealthy and
what gets you away from the wolf's door
and stuff when stuff like a pandemic
hits yeah and it's the long game there's
no short-term fix
no yeah beverly seals said it no
shortcut to any place worth going
that's a great quote this is a good
quote no shortcut to any place it's
worth it
takes the time but it's worth it yeah
it's you know there's not a pill to make
you lose weight
and there's not a pill to get you out of
debt there's not a microwave
you just got to freaking do it this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free
stage joshua and julia are with us hey
guys
welcome happy new year happy new year
you're the first
in person debt-free scream of the year
awesome awesome well done i love it how
much have you paid
off 347 000
um in six and a half years roughly
wow and your range of income during that
time of
155 000 to 250 000.
cool what do you guys do for a living
i'm a nurse in ethicist
i stay home with kids okay great and i'm
going to guess with the length of time
and the amount of money you paid off
your house
we sure did it
i've been waiting so long to hear you
say that people are in front of me
that's right so what's this house worth
right around 350 000.
okay and it's yours it's all right bye
guys
i love it way to go you guys i love
mowing the grass
every blade is ours because it's yours
that's how that works
i love it i'm so proud of y'all how old
are you i'm 35
33 and you're paid for house yes sir you
are officially weird
man how many 35 year old friends do you
have with a paid for house
a lot of them tell us to not do it yeah
that's crazy okay so what made you do
this like i understand that getting out
of debt but it's like we're gonna just
we're gonna hit the gear and pay off the
house right so we're both
fbu babies i grew up on the envelope
system and josh did a seventh grade
algebra homework from the back of the
fbu classroom so
it was a no-brainer obviously to pay off
the student loans as soon as soon as he
graduated from
anesthesia school and we took a little
bit of a break
started a family and then it came to
where we needed to decide do we put an
extra sum of money toward retirement or
do we pay off the house and of course
we got a lot of people saying why would
you pay off your house don't pay off
your house
at that time we were leading an fpu
course and
through that we became more accountable
to
the dave ramsey plan and we became more
of a team
budget meetings were more of a joy than
a burden or a dread
and it we were always exciting to me
nerd free spirit let's just establish it
and so um with uh with leading that
class we decided all right we're going
to pay off the house but
even at that point i was i was a
supporter but i wasn't an
equal partner in in the process
so i wasn't really gung-ho about it
until
about february of 2019 when we had
received
a late advent calendar from our friends
in germany and we're all sitting in the
living room
floor pouring over these german
chocolates and goodies
when josh said how would you guys like
to take a trip to germany which of
course the response was i bribed them
i think i needed a bribe this response
was yeah yeah we want to go to germany
and he said all right when when we pass
the house we'll go to germany well so at
that point
we became we became full partners
in this and um so the interesting part
though is when god came into it um
the very next month we we had decided
obviously to pay off the house
but whenever i was starting to do the
numbers like i always do i realized that
that was going to be a lot of money to
pay off 198
000 in about well it was january 2000
we're going to do it by january 2021
yeah that was the date we decided
at that time that february of 2019 um
we had 198 000 left in the house and i
was like this is
this is outrageous how in the world
we're going to do this so i started
talking to god and
i said god if you don't mind just give
us more work not more money more work
and um that very next month in march i
had five co-workers
that put in their notice to leave oh my
god and i sat down with her and i said
i'm not sure if god sent them out of my
work
but it is an opportunity for me to get
all the overtime i could
and so i'm amped all my every vacation i
had for the last two years uh every
post-call day which i have most of them
off
i worked all of them many saturdays i
worked and uh so i have not been
part of jeremiah's life pretty much in
my um
so for that whole 18 months uh it was
gung-ho yeah and uh so god provided um
that opportunity for us and we got it
done in time actually
four months early i guess wow i mean
while we're learning german so that we
can keep them accountable to his part of
the plan
his bribe yeah the kids are really that
was a pretty heavy sacrifice all those
hours
it was uh but now you're 35 years old
with a paid-for home
was it worth it i would never go back
yeah absolutely
uh the hardest part was uh just
parenting is hard enough alone or in and
of itself but parenting alone is even
harder and it felt like that some nights
when i was the only one tucking them in
bed
most of my hours were 24 hours at 16 to
24 hour shifts i mean i'm
i'm working call and and then getting up
the next morning and working 10
12 16 hours so it wasn't just like
monday through friday seven to five
it was constant but because because we
paid off our house we were able to say
yes to an opportunity that we
would have just not even batted our eyes
at so uh
august september or august somewhere
around there when i got the money
because i was waiting for it when the
money came into the check checking
account to be able to pay the house off
that morning when it came in i got a
call an hour later from my buddy who
went into school anesthesia school with
me asking me for
if i would like to interview for a job
about 45 minutes away from my job now
i accepted the job um pretty much a week
later
and i am now home with my family so much
more
and i didn't really sacrifice my pay at
all i actually got a bit of a pay raise
wow so without the hours without the
other hours
i actually feel like it was god saying
okay you asked for the time of work and
now i'm going to close it out with a
another huge gift wow and so we are
extremely grateful to be here today
here's the cupcake here's some icing
yeah i like it he was faithful for sure
amen that's powerful dude and you know
the way we know that's god for those of
you who don't know anything about god is
the timing
is wacky there's no other way to explain
it
that just generally happened in the
middle of this then you could blame it
on coincidence or something like that
if you believed in that kind of stuff
but this is like i need some more work
okay here's some work and i just
finished paying off the house
oh here's the same amount of money for
less work and covert never did slow us
down
yeah we picked up more hours during that
time so yeah
it was a blessing oh you guys that's
incredible i mean
absolutely incredible people stand on
the stage that are all
ranges of age but seeing young people
without a mortgage payment like you guys
like that's
insane absolutely insane and and it was
it was a short-term sacrifice right like
we don't always say to go gazelle
intense
through those baby steps but you chose
to which is great in that short amount
that 18 months which girl
three kids i can't even i know i like
the same as you i'm like oh
so bathtime's the worst like i know it's
so hard yeah
but that short-term sacrifice and now
the freedom the absolute freedom to even
pull back more if you wanted right i
mean
just nothing it's awesome and in the
middle of that somebody was leading
financial peace university classes what
do you tell them
in the class when they ask okay
yeah but you make a lot of money what's
the secret to getting out of that
my dad has always told me you're going
to spend as much as you make
you're going to spend it in for us our
priority was
in the house but for a lot of people
it's things that they can't even really
remember what they spend it on
um so it's just being focused um
you got to determine a plan and i highly
encourage bringing your wife on board as
well
um it is a it's a marriage uh you can't
do it alone
and once she when she committed with the
germany bribe
once she committed it there was nothing
stopping her so when are you going to
germany
well we were going to go this year but
it's going to be 2022 because that's
when this lady that we're friends with
is going to get married so we're going
to be there for her marriage
for her wedding awesome now then you'll
have a thorough understanding of the
german language by the time you get
there
yeah oh yeah we'll be fluent all right
bring the three kiddos in and introduce
them their names and ages or what
go on guys josiah is six mm-hmm
and jeremiah's two almost two and we've
gotta we gotta tell y'all a little bit
about them
so uh one day when i was gone josh
took the kids and made a paper chain
with them
each link representing a thousand
dollars that we had left on the house
and each time we made a payment it
wasn't it was a family affair we went
through our ritual
of making the payment on the computer as
a family and cutting off the appropriate
amount of chains
and it was a great visual but now that i
stand here on the stage i think about
how
debt has you in chain count it down
before we run out of time all right
let's hear your death
cry we're dead
[Applause]
well done you guys that's as good as
celebrations i've had a long time
wow precious amazing amazing amazing
well done well played this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ephesians 4 29
let no corrupting talk
come out of your mouths but only such
as is good for building up as
fits the occasion that it may give grace
to those who hear
amy poehler said limit your always
and your nevers
yeah i don't agree with that limit your
always
and your nevers don't never get too
extreme limit the time you say always
and the time that you say never's
never unless you're just being a drama
queen but i mean there's some things you
need to say
never how many times have you disagree
with the quotes
almost never
i never disagree with you i always
disagree with quotes
because they're like i guess because
she's saying because they're extremes
yeah that's what she's trying to say but
that my point is is that there are
principles in your life that you should
always
stick to and some things you should
never do
it's fair i don't know i wish i had an
argument to play devil's advocate but i
genuinely don't i agree with you
one of your favorite sports is arguing
with me so this is scary the first time
i'm worried about you we need to
we need to have your temperature checked
you're always fun to debate with oh it's
good how many people push your buttons
i can push your buttons hogan hogan and
me argue all the time
no on the airline like us yes we do yes
we do he makes fun of me all the time
for being bald
hurts my feelings okay i'm sensitive
that way
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five don't forget
one week from today on tuesday january
the 12th we will be doing the reset
live stream it is a free live stream
with chris hogan rachel cruz craig
groeschel and me
it is time for you to hit the reset
button it is time for you to get the
step-by-step
money plan to do the small things you
need to do for 90 days that are going to
show you how to get on track and get
moving we're going to lay it all out for
you
so go to daveramsey.com reset and you
can check out
the whole thing having to do with ramsey
plus and getting a free trial to it
and if you want to view the
free reset live stream to kickstart your
money goals for 2021
text the word reset two three three
seven eight nine
text reset two three three
seven eight nine there'll be a hundred
two hundred fifty thousand folks
watching
that live stream that night based we've
already got 65 000 and we have a week to
go
and it's free by the way tell people
about it tell your friends about it they
can start off 2021
with the best minds on the subjects
of behavior and money behavior around
money all of that
amy is with us in uh flint michigan hi
amy how can we help
hi dave hi rachel hey how are you
good how are you good how can we help
so i had in the spring actually right
when coveted hit i had an issue with
mold in my house
i have since got it fixed insurance
covered it and everything
but i have been diagnosed with mold
toxicity
so unfortunately i am working from home
and have been since about march and i
got a permanent position at home now
i have now found another mold spot in my
house
that has to be taken care of so i'm not
really sure how to go about it
you know my insurance mold coverage is
maxed out so
do i take out a loan
to take care of all the mold because my
health comes first
i mean i they're talking maybe up to ten
thousand dollars worth of damage
and i'm just not sure exactly how to go
about it because i
you know i'm trying to file your plan i
know that you know i don't want to be
slave to the lender i don't want to take
out another loan
but i know that my health comes first so
i'm not really sure how to go about it
are you single i am
what's your household income
it's about 36. and you obviously own
this home
yeah i have two roommates
what's the house worth
um probably about
130ish to 140.
[Music]
and what do you owe on it
about 110.
so a ten thousand dollar loan when you
make thirty six thousand dollars a year
is what's known as a
lot of money
yeah okay
well i i don't wanna put your health in
jeopardy and i don't
know enough about you being diagnosed
with mold toxicity as far as i
understood we all have mold toxicity
um so it's new to me that some people
haven't some don't i
don't know i'm not being smart like i
just don't know i know it's not good for
anybody uh is my point
and so if you've got a special uh level
of sensitivity to it which is i suspect
what you're saying
um then obviously it escalates the
situation
i've been doing this show 30 years and
i've been put
personally in a whole bunch of corners
where
the it looked like the only way i was
borrowing money but i a long time ago
gave up the idea of borrowing money so i
can't recommend you borrow money so i
have to recommend something else
because i wouldn't do it myself and i
especially wouldn't do it if i made
thirty six thousand dollars a year and
one borrow ten thousand dollars for the
second go-round of mold on the same
stinking house
i'd sell this house and move
this is to come up again what are you
going to do next time it's ten thousand
dollars
i mean this house has got a mold problem
or for some reason it's got a
susceptibility
to a new area of the house amy like why
didn't they fix it in the first place
yeah
yeah this is a whole new area that's
what i would say i would say you didn't
fix it
well the insurance max out but you
didn't fix the problem i had mold in my
house
and now i still have mold in my house so
like that's on them they
they need to fix it in my opinion
yeah i know but they had a they had a
certain amount they were
the insurance company had a cap your
homeowner's mold coverage only
went up to a certain amount yeah but
that they needed to explain that to her
then to say we can only fix x amount
it's like they didn't even find the
other stuff
well she knew she might you knew you
maxed out your insurance on the first
repair right
yeah and i didn't find this new spot
until
um just last week yeah but and the point
is though that it's
uh if ten thousand dollars is correct
that was a pretty substantial miss
rachel's saying by the mold people
i mean if there's a ten thousand dollars
worth of mold damage and you finished
work just a few months ago
they missed something right
it had to already be there yeah this one
was kind of hidden in the attic and i
don't know if they really did
enough checking in the attic before yeah
yeah they missed it
so um you know i don't know
what it means to your health if you can
afford to live there for a little while
without damaging your health i don't
know that i don't know how to explain
that
i know that dave and sharon ramsey had a
lot of different things come up
that felt like they were impossible
situations and we were put in a corner
where we had to make
horrible choices uh but to avoid debt
and never going back again we made those
choices and now 20 years later
we're extremely prosperous because we
made those choices well and what it does
amy when you
kind of make that line in the sand and
you just say no matter what we're not
borrowing money
that forces you to see other options
and then you get creative and then you
say you know what maybe i will just sell
the house
or maybe i'm gonna get out and have the
roommates help i mean you start to
actually look at different options
versus just yielding to debt
when you have that stance and so the
fact that you're a little bit
you're kind of wish you washed a little
bit in your questions maybe your career
maybe you've got to work on your career
because you don't make any money
and you know you got to work on maybe
you're going to be working outside the
home
uh to make more money and um
that would be okay too uh because you're
you know
average household income is 59 000 in
america and i'm not picking on you i'm
not shaming you for what you're making
i'm just saying that long term uh
five years from now what are you going
to be doing that makes use 80 000
a year instead of 36 and you need to be
aiming at that
and that might be part of the fix for
this ten thousand dollar problem
it might be the extra job that you take
on and you go make ten thousand dollars
in a couple of months
and uh you work your tail end off over
the next three months and you make ten
thousand bucks
and you pay cash for this fix that's
okay with me if you wanna do that
uh if you can survive your health for
three for those three months i don't
i don't know how sensitive this
situation is but if it's super sensitive
to where you're going to be seriously
ill in the next 30 days out of the house
then you need to move and you need to
put the house up for sale
and you need to not try to try to fix a
moldy house all the time let's just move
on
that puts this hour of the dave ramsey
showing the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
[Music]
jesus
[Music]
you